salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche et
c'est le jour où je vous explique
quelque chose de mentalist hic pour
bluffer à votre tour vous êtes comme je
le fais de temps en temps je vais
d'abord vous le faire à vous à travers
l'écran pour que vous puissiez vivre
l'expérience et après je vous expliquer
comment ça se passe je vais avoir besoin
de lire les lignes de votre main vous
allez tendre votre main gauche c'est à
dire l'autre celle ci voit là et vous la
placez devant l'écran pour que je puisse
bien analyser les lignes de votre main
attention je vais m'approcher un petit
peu de la caméra ça va me faire une
grosse tête
tout ce que je vois pour le moment c'est
que j'ai les yeux proche de l'écran et
qui a pas votre main metella a vraiment
joué le jeu je vais je même que deux
secondes
d'accord ça c'est intéressant ça aussi
j'ai l'impression que je louche parfait
vous pouvez enlever votre main j'ai tout
ce qu'il me faut je sais exactement si
vous êtes je sais exactement qui tu es
toi spécifiquement toi comme je parle
spécifiquement de toi je me permet de
tutoyer je pense par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu dans les lignes de ta main que
tu es un ami loyal honnête dévoué
quelqu'un sur qui on peut vraiment
compter en cas de coup dur je pense
aussi que tu es beaucoup plus ambitieux
que ce que tes amis tes camarades ta
famille ne le pense de ce que j'ai vu
sur les lignes descendante tu dois être
quelqu'un d'assez fort qui dégage une
impression de stabilité alors qu'au fond
de toi il arrive parfois t'inquiéter de
l'avenir je pense au site est assez
perfectionniste ce qui peut d'ailleurs
parfois énervés les gens autour de toi
tu sais d'ailleurs et c'est très bien
peser le pour et le contre
plutôt que de conclure hâtivement qui
fait que tu es le genre de personne qui
aime bien être en possession de toutes
les données de toutes les informations
avant de prendre une décision quand tu
regarde derrière toi tu penses des fois
des choses que tu aurais pu faire
autrement
mais d'une manière générale tapas et de
tendance là tu vas plutôt de l'avant
bien tu aimes le changement la nouveauté
la variété d'apprécier quand même une
forme de routine de stabilité en fait de
chose que tu connais que tu reconnais et
apparemment où on mange je te parles tu
as une grande décision à prendre quelque
chose d'important ou alors tu viens
juste de vivre un grand bouleversement
un grand changement que tu sais
pertinemment que tu as beaucoup de
capacités que tu n'utilises pas et
d'ailleurs des fois tu te dis je vais le
faire et puis après bon ben je voulais
pas le faire et a vraiment deux facettes
à une facette vraiment sociable
extroverti et il ya un autre côté de toi
qu'on connaît parfois un peu moins qui
est plus réservé en fait plus solitaire
en réalité voilà ce que m'ont dit les
lignes de ta main et je pense que c'est
juste un petit peu flippant non comment
ça fonctionne et bien je
vous le dirai évidemment c'est le but du
dimanche le texte est basé
principalement sur les films barnum
c'est à dire qu on recadre nous mêmes
par rapport à ce qu'on est vraiment à
notre propre vie à nos propres souvenirs
à qui on veut être ce texte là n'est pas
de moi il est d'un psychologue qui
s'appelle foreurs il a mis ce texte là
au point fin des années 40 pour faire un
test en fait sur des étudiants
il a donné ce test pour tester l'effet
barnaby s'est aperçu que la plupart de
ces étudiants trouver le texte
extrêmement précis dans ce crunch faith
in the mirror que caputo a écrit en 2010
il reparle de ça c'est strenx faith in
the mirror illusionnent d'ailleurs de
tout ce qu'on peut dire qu'il est
applicable à tout le monde où tout le
monde va se sentir en réalité concernés
c'est un petit peu comme un texte
placebo c'est nous mentalement avec nos
recadrage une propres souvenirs qui
donnons du crédit à tout ça le script
est assez long et à chaque fois qu'il ya
un script selon vous me dites dans les
commentaires et pourquoi tu ne l'a pas
écrit pourquoi qu'il l'a pas donnée je
vous mets un lien dans les commentaires
c'est un lien sur mon site internet où
je vous ai mis ça ça vous permettra de
le télécharger en pdf prenez le temps de
l'apprendre par coeur ce sera beaucoup
plus crédible si vous ne savez pas
comment apprendre un texte par coeur
regardez la vidéo d'hier je vous
l'expliquais termes de présentation
trouvait toujours un angle lisait dans
du marc de café regarder dans les lignes
de la main
demandez à une personne de vous citer
les cinq premiers chiffres qui lui
viennent et fait une analyse
psychologique d'elle en tout cas trouvé
une motivation au départ et vous allez
voir la personne sera vraiment bluffé
surtout si c'est quelqu'un que vous
connaissez pas ou peu ou à peine que
vous venez de rencontrer je ne vous
avais jamais fait d'explication de ce
type là si vous voulez d'autres
explications d'ailleurs on a signal
entre nous 1 vous pouvez me le faire
savoir
housse en l'air une autre manière
également de le tester sur vos amis
c'est de partager cette vidéo est de
voir les retours qui vous feront dans
les commentaires en parlant de
commentaire vous pouvez en laisser un je
le lirai pas c'est un excellent dimanche
et rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour
le prochain mentale blog ciao